all right don't worry we're not going to
spend a ton of time on this but i do
want to go over the last sort of 24
hours of reactions from the trump camp
to the january 6 trump riot committee
hearings we're first going to look at
some of the things that donald trump
posted to his platform truth social
truth essential of course and we're also
going to look at a supposed 12-page
letter that trump wrote well let me say
it a different way it's a 12-page letter
a 12-page letter that trump supposedly
wrote we're going to look at that as
well so let's start with truth essential
or truth social donald trump going
absolutely bonkers on his uh social
media platform about these hearings
starting with quote
word out that the reason the unselects
have canceled wednesday's kangaroo court
is a total lack of interest leading to
very poor television ratings could this
be so maybe they should try getting a
more talented hollywood producer than
the former president of abc fake news he
didn't do so well so this is a um
a calculated uh talking point from
republicans that the nobody cares about
the hearings now of course it's not true
listen it's not the super bowl okay we
all acknowledge that
these are boring hearings by traditional
standards although i've found them quite
riveting myself
but there were about 22 million people
who watch the first night of broadcast
that doesn't include any of the online
audiences which were which were huge so
the the audience has actually been fine
trump then on truth social saying quote
does anybody notice that the unselect
committee refuses to discuss or debate
in any way shape or form the many
irrefutable types of election fraud and
irregularities found in the 2020
election this is cancel culture because
they know that they have zero chance of
winning that debate so sad to see our
capital seat country falling apart now
the opposite is true in fact
every
single allegation of voter fraud
or irregularities
has been
significantly refuted not only have they
been refuted by republicans in testimony
during the committee hearings including
from william barr and others
every single claim has been investigated
close to 70 such claims were brought to
courts and the courts found that there
was no merit or that there was no
standing i will gladly say some of the
courts took it as a standing issue
allegations of supposed dead voters were
investigated the voters were found alive
and well
a handful you know died after legally
voting absentee and then they died by
election day or by the day that the
investigation was done there was some
junior senior confusion it's it's been
investigated
massive dumps as donald trump uh uh
likes to say you know you know about
that big massive dumps yeah big massive
dumps of voting votes in boxes
being brought in overnight it's been
looked at it's been widely debunked
all of these claims have actually been
refuted and so donald trump just lying
there trump then posting to truth social
the unselect committee refused to debate
the election results the reason for the
massive crowd on january 6 because they
can't and again
they are in the position
of wanting something unreasonable
we have election results election
results are not something we debate we
don't say hey you know what um
we i believe that a flat tax is best for
the economy and you believe a
progressive tax is best for the economy
let's debate it and each bring forward
our perspectives and historical evidence
no no we
we counted the ballots and joe biden won
when there have been audits or recounts
done
joe biden won that's it it's there's no
there's nothing to debate as far as that
goes then donald trump posting the
unselects are going against me because i
am the only one who can fix our
endangered country
and they want to destroy it people want
to go back to where we were just two
years ago
again the weaponized narcissism only i
can fix it all of the things trump told
us he would fix during his presidency he
did not fix
and then trump also attacking william
barr william barr who by the way still
said he would vote for trump over a
democrat in 2024 for all of the
criticism that barr has levied against
trump he still said oh i'm not going to
vote for a democrat if it's trump versus
a democrat in 2024 i'll vote for trump
even though he said that trump is
furious with barr because barr said yeah
all of these claims are bs and trump
posting quote former attorney generally
bill barr
a rhino
if there ever was one a rhino named mitt
romney
yeah a rhino means republican in name
only um he didn't have the stamina or
courage to go after vote fraud
was afraid he was going to be impeached
no guts no glory so trump turning on
william barr as well really losing it
now these things trump definitely did
write what we're going to look at next i
don't believe trump wrote my audience
knows i read i read a ton of books i
read nonfiction i read fiction at night
i'm always trying to consume information
and the truth is i don't have the time
to read every non-fiction book that i
would like to read one thing i do not
have time to add to what i'm reading in
paper form is more history but i want to
know about history and that's where our
sponsor blinkist comes in blinkist
doesn't replace reading books cover to
cover the way i love to do but for
example with everything going on right
now with roe v wade i wanted more of a
detailed history of roe v wade in the
united states so on blinkist i was able
to get a 15-minute condensed audiobook
of the mary ziegler book abortion and
the law in america roe v wade to the
present and in 15 minutes i get a great
overview blinkist also has slide
presentations that will take you about
15 minutes to go through so it's not to
replace reading it's in addition to for
me you get the key takeaways from
blinkist from the books i would
certainly otherwise miss out on you can
try blinkist for free for seven days and
get a 25 discount off of a subscription
com slash pacman the link is down below